confirmation hearings for the president
Secretary of State nominee Mike Pompeo
will be led by retiring Republican
senator bob Corker Foreign Relations
Committee Chairman spoke with Face the
Nation moderator Margaret Brennan for
Sunday's broadcast she is in Washington
with part of that interview Margaret
good morning good morning well there are
a lot of questions here in Washington
about whether the president is going to
use Rex Tillerson Zhou ster as a chance
to make further changes to his national
security team and I spoke to Senator
corker yesterday about some of the very
big foreign policy issues that are going
to be confronting the incoming secretary
Mike Pompeo do you think the president
should sit down with Kim jong-un I think
it's fine it look it's going to happen
you do believe that meetings going to
happen I think ultimately it happens I
do and I think that that's why the
president likes to deal with things and
I think that what you're going to see is
people who have a lot of institutional
knowledge prepping for the meeting
you've seen the administration sort of
move away from an instant meeting
they've said that you know they don't
know exactly when it's going to occur
well I think you're seeing that happen
because the realities of what you have
to do in preparation to make sure that
it's successful it takes a while for
that to occur and we do have back
channels ourselves by the way to North
Korea and you know we have our ways of
setting things like that up in an
appropriate manner now senator corker
also said that he expects President
Trump will decide in May to pull out of
that international agreement to freeze
Iran's nuclear program so John this
could be a really interesting decision
given that the talks will be about
freezing North Korea's nuclear program
yeah so senator corker was the one who
rather colorfully said that Rex
Tillerson was being castrated by the
president he has talked to Tillerson
since the firing and What did he say
about that you're right corker he was a
little bit more diplomatic in the
language he used yesterday but he has
been one of Rex Tillerson very few
allies in Washington he had a long
with him after Tillerson was fired and
said he's at peace Tillerson had planned
to stay on the job for another year but
it has been a rough and tumble one for
him not only due to the policy
disagreements with the president but
also because of his personality he was
very deliberate and his approach just
didn't mesh with the president's more
chaotic management style and so
secretary Tillerson we know was very
surprised to be fired by tweet but
according to bob Corker he feels like he
did leave with some progress having been
made with north korea so he hopes
that'll be more of his legacy would you
if confirmed CIA director Mike Pompeo
will take over the State Department how
do you see things changing well he's got
a good rapport with the president and
there is hope certainly at the State
Department that that'll mean something
to unstick some of these personnel
vacancies that maybe he'll be able to
staff up the building breathe in some
vitality senator corker wouldn't be
pinned down and just when Mike Pompeo
might be confirmed he just said it'll be
sometime in April and there's a lot of
pressure here in Washington to get a
Secretary of State in place not only
because of that upcoming decision on
Iran but also what's happening with
North Korea you've got a number of key
foreign policy issues bubbling up in May
elections in Iraq and there's concern
that that post should not remain vacant
for very long all right thanks so much
Margaret Face the Nation will air more
of the interview with Senator corker
this Sunday Margaret we'll also talk
with Republican Senator Rand Paul and
independent senator angus King shall
also ask South Korea's foreign minister
about the upcoming talks with the north
let's face the nation Sunday here on CBS